So, um, as I said before, the tone my,
but we will look at what's developed
and how the wall in Etsy graph 2002
presented. So it's all, it has,
it had already some time to prove
itself, so to say. Um, it's widely used,
so most a light simulation brotox
and also HDR photography tools,
you have it and it has both
a global and a local variant.
So they were both present
here.
You'll see the difference between a
global and the local approach. Yeah,
you can come.
Um, yes, in some way.
I mean I'm usually
convolutions by fixed Carmel.
So your kernel function
is the same. Um, here,
this could be a nonlinear car.
So it's not that it's linear convolution
in the sense that you have one fixed
cargo,
the toss it,
but you have a non linear
mapping in this sense.
It's not really convolution,
but the implementations can are in spirit.
So if you want to have it fast,
it's apparent elation,
parallelization strategies that work
for convolutions of the work for them.
Yeah.
Um,
usually you,
I will go into the local approach later,
but you usually have to
attempt the feature size.
So I don't you do multiple passes with
different discretization of your calls
size or you taking a huge call
and very different function. So,
okay,
okay. Here the difference between a
global and the local approach. Um,
I'm not hundred percent sure how vital
this is perceivable this bro check door
for example.
You see that the local approach,
it's much more contrast in the
coop my path or for example,
in the, um, in the
mosaics on the judgment.
I think an older one
already works very well,
is faster,
but it doesn't give you all the
possibilities that your I would give you.
So the steps,
these are just a short outline.
I will explain what this meant
with this formula does of course,
if we want to have in
depth details on this, um,
the references at the end of the lecture.
So I'm here,
I present the global version.
So you will now have one mapping
function off the whole image or of the
luminance values of the whole image to Eh,
um,
color space.
So the first thing you do is you compute
some kind of average of the image.
So since you do not know if this is,
is this inherently a very
dark image or is it um,
globally a very bright image,
you somehow have to set
the baseline so to say,
and this is done with the log average,
so you don't just ever age the,
um,
the sun, so you don't sum up in
divide because this would give,
um,
unproportional weight to the large
values because they are some help
exponentially distribute that. You can
imagine. So this takes care of that.
So you're um,
okay,
you ever h in log space and 10
convert back into explanation.
Okay.
And then you have some kind
of average of your scene.
So this is the approximate
average brightness of the
image that I'm looking at.
And then you met this
to a middle gray value.
So a is now what,
what do you define as you want to
have middle gray. This you can vary.
This also depends on what the
ranges you have available.
And this now sets the bar so everything
above this medical grade will be
brighter, everything below
would be darker. And then
um,
what you do is you take the
middle grade value and um,
skate sampled accordingly to it.
So now you don't have a input in some
kind of arbitrary range but you have it
relative to the middle
grade where you and Ben,
what you do is that your compress
the high Luminance's. So as, um,
if you're a member from before our
distribution division by a maximum,
which gave you just a single
bright spot in the image,
this is because the high
lumen answers dominate,
usually dominate the scene but are only,
have very small extent in the senior
sales imagined looking at the sun.
I mean the son is very small when
compared to the whole skydome but it would
dominate it as immensely
higher uprightness values
than the surrounding blue of
the sky. So what you do here
is not that you are men,
you're escaped nominates values to the
final output by compressing the higher
Luminance's.
So in the lower right
you see the function,
the mapping function.
So, um, as you see that,
Eh,
a huge range save from Daniel four to
10 in the x axis is mapped to a rather
small part in the y axis.
That means that um,
a lot of uh, large Luminance's
are just compressed in a small,
um,
range in a say RGB values.
And what you also have is
that the small luminance,
so to the small Lumina answers in
the input file or in the input image,
um, are mapped to a larger
extent. On the y axis.
This,
you can see that there are slow of the
faction starts out as nearly vertical
Lee.
Okay,
go at a 45 degree,
you will have a one one mapping
which is approximately a two.
And then you have a compression.
So well what this mapping to us it,
it compresses the high lumen answers
and enhances the low Luminance's.
And this thank to the mapping
and you can convert this into,
so I go back.
So the output lumen answers,
then half are in a predefined range from
zero to one and can then be mapped to
whatever color space you like.
Okay,
so the local version, this is now the one
that takes the neighbors into account,
starts off similarly.
So your computer log ever ridge to get
an estimate is the average brightness of
my scene. Then you're met
the values to average gray.
That means that the value
of one is now my, uh,
the middle of gray to the defined.
But now I do not compress the luminance
by one uniform function over the whole
image, but then locally at depth this
function by looking at the neighbors.
So now, um, this,
um, the local average, um,
upper case B now depends
not only on the coordinates in the image,
so x and y.
So the Pixel that I'm there right now,
but it also depends on some kind of scale.
The scale means how uniform and
my brightness distributions there.
So we are,
I am I at a say a silhouette
where half of it is very dark,
half of it is very bright or min a
homogeneous region because in homogeneous
regions I would adapt,
uh,
on the extent on the rate
dinner to this brightness.
And if it's accommodated
to this brightness, it can
differentiate details better.
Um, you perhaps have already experienced
that when you look at the moon.
So if you look quickly at the moon,
it's just a bright spot,
but the longer you look at it,
the more details you can discern.
This is an adaptation of your iTunes.
And this happens also at a
local sports of the retina.
And this is what seem related here.
So you compute for every pixel position x,
y,
and locals came.
Yeah.
And with this local scale your time,
um,
you compute the local average v and
this now gives you how much range
compression is going to
happen at this location.
Okay.
So, um, so how to get this came.
So this case is, um, the extent
of an area around to speak for whether
brightness doesn't change too much.
So in this example where
you have a colorful, um,
church window does,
is that is illuminated from outside.
You have three different
examples on how your,
um, Ken puts the influence
re regional for your scheme.
So that land,
how tall [inaudible] asked this
by computing to [inaudible]
and then look at the
[inaudible],
um,
[inaudible] them in a way that
they have a certain behavior.
So in the very top you'll see your assume
that the pixel is in the center of the
two concentric circles.
So this is the biggest goal
that I want to talk about now.
And if I lie,
if I bought two concentric
small circles around it,
then I see that, um, that the center area,
the smaller circle is quite smooth
in the distribution of brightnesses.
But the Alto Circle,
it's very smooth too.
So there is no significant difference
between the small and the large circle.
That means that my scale is too small.
That means that I could enlarge
my circle even more. And stealing,
um,
retains smoothness.
In the center example,
you see the correct
application so that the center,
this has smooth values.
So they are approximately
the same brightness.
But if you take now the outer
circle that intersects the window,
you see that suddenly in this footprint,
very large values are.
So you'll see that the
small circle is smooth,
but the surrounding area is not smooth.
And this is what you want to achieve
when you determined the local skate.
So the larger the local scale is the,
the more, um, you are looking
at the large patch of equal,
um, brightnesses and your,
I would adapt to that.
That means that for this pixel you can
improve the contrast because I will do
the same. Um, and other failure case,
what you should not do is that you
make the piece too large as the,
as shown in the bottom example because
your bright values already in the
northeast.
Okay?
So this scale,
it would be too large.
Okay.
Um, I go back. So what you get, but this,
when you notice k,
you know,
yeah,
how large the region is, where you
can compute your local area average.
And this then allows you to
locally compress your range.
So if it's very smooth,
you compress less.
If you're next to very bright boundaries,
you're,
so if you're there,
if you're next to these continuities
in the brightness and your image,
so they are,
you are at the verge of traversing from
bright to dim region or vice versa.
You go to the opposite.
Yeah.
The ratio between the larger radius.
Constance.
Exactly.
Yeah.
This is the approach that you take
there and then you have to find this,
I mean they are also show
you an implementation.
All this can be efficiently mapped because
I mean triangle all the possible, um,
circles is,
or this is not feasible so you need some
kind of approximation that gives you a
good estimate of that also is he goes
to the corner of the immune system.
Um, yeah. I mean, I mean I don't
know how they handled it is,
but I would guess that he just ignore
everything that's out of the image.
So you have to cope with your,
do you have there and,
but this is natural in
the corners of your image.
You get less neighborhood so you get
less information of all the surrounding
looks like. So you will get,
say less optimal tone maybe.
So I'm here, uh, another difference, uh,
assuming the image before.
So as you can see,
the angel fingers on the wall are much
higher contrast and this is now because
the brightness whale you
around or relatively,
so if you're calm prds with
say the window next to it,
then this has a very uniform brightness.
Even if the colors are perhaps different,
this is still a low range as you
saw before. Between sun and moon,
it was 800,000.
Between Black and white,
it was 100 or 1000. So, um,
if you have direct or
indirect illumination counts
much more than just color
variations of your surface.
So here, the Dole mapper,
correct, the deck clean, it's local verse.
She that the brightness values
are quite uniform in this region,
so it enhances the contrast.
So,
um, now this wall of this,
uh, concludes the Rialto met,
but there are also other,
um, told mapping approaches.
So in this,
um,
see graph 2002 was the year of the tone
may bus because there were three tone,
I think, uh, approaches presented. Um,
so one of those was a bilateral filter.
Perhaps you already heard of
Bellator filtering in, um,
computer vision perhaps.
Um, they are, this is,
you can imagine it as a Darshan
smoothing that does not move away ages.
So if you have a large
difference in your image,
then it does not smooth decently.
So this is,
you can also call it age
preserving smooth thing.
And um,
you can imagine that this is
somehow conception similar
to this skein estimation
of a handheld because the scale estimation
books where do the brightness values,
um,
define lot.
So these are saved my brightness ahs
in the image and then it doesn't try to
propagate contrast enhancement or what
his age and the bilateral fifth dose can
do the same thing because he just
stopped the filtering process at ages.
Then another approach by
photog great end processing,
um, this is, um,
you can imagine an image,
say you have only illuminates
channel of a single,
um, color. Then you can imagine
your image as a height Farfetch.
So bright spots,
um,
correspond to high peaks
team regions too low valleys.
And what they do in this work is
that the look at the gradients.
So Hall's deep are the slopes in my
image and then they compress ingredient
range does it allows them to um,
to per surf low gradients because these
are small slopes are the Arctic details
in the team layer illuminated regions
and the s and a very high slopes are
there. Um, Duran pops to the
bright spots. So if your chest,
um,
say reduce the high gradients,
you also get a similar
behavior that your own way, um,
reduce the range in non uniform regions.
So these are three approaches
that do approximately the same.
They have the same underlying idea but
they have different approaches to it.
So they're one of our Hanhardt
those more into what what's used in,
um,
in photography with their disease
exposure plates that you can use.
Bilateral filtering immediately uses
are whale established filtering,
partaken in signal processing,
but it's most likely very suboptimal
from a perceptual point of view.
Um,
gradient processing allows a very fast
application but perceptionally of these
who works there and how to
make this the best and um,
this speed increases the
two perhaps needed, um,
13 years ago and not really relevant now.
So you don't need to take approximations
that we're highly relevant before into
account anymore and just do the and just
have something that's less efficient
but gives you a lot of the
box, nice solution. And uh,
we feel check we can be there.
Um,
the German version has along
the list, um, the least,
approximately 20 different variants.
Um,
the literature for debt is brand hut
not only started that but also continued
research and that, and he's a con, uh,
seen as one of the say experts that
to go to when to mapping is concerned.
He wrote a book about that.
So heightened emigre ng change.
Um,
and you can also see this three papers
if you want to know how to speak
developed, um, you just check for example,
there are and how to paper on
the Digital Library of ACM.
You can, uh, to lose from here, from
the university. So you get an a car,
you get immediate access to the whole
Digital Library of ACM and they are,
you can just click on site that buy and
then you get the long list of papers
that referenced the original work about
and hot and then you can sort them by a
years and look what different
approaches were used.
Good. That concludes the tone. I've
been parts. Are there any questions?
Okay. If not, oral
method is used cameos?
MMM,
to some extent.
because I mean you're inherently
losing information because,
okay.
The sate of thing where you for sure lose
precision is if you have before say 24
Pete venues and then you're in
Colton in eight beat RGB values.
Then you have a conversation
of your brightness ratings.
This is unrecovered.
This is just lost.
The other thing is if you use
local approaches that take
that, take up the neighborhood information
to account and then through different
things in different regions of the image,
then it could be that you have some
kind of ambig curiosity if you want to
reverse this process because then
it could be that you're either had,
say in original data,
large brightness Barrios and as a,
at a small scale or a large range
compression then or the range was already
small like that and you'll just
use less compression. So you,
um,
you do not have the full information how
local approaches adapt to certain parts
of the image.
You will have to infer this somehow,
I would guess like a
customization approach.
So you've looked like that locally.
You should have the same skein that you
assume that you reconstruct and then you
can recover you're seeking,
but you will not be able to recover it
with global approach us. It
should be possible. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yup.
Combined goal and the local
ones is the right one.
Tournament does any way equal
amounts within global one?
That's a local one. If you look here, um,
the local version has, uh,
please express she, so the,
um,
the scales normally names is then
divided by some kind of local average.
And the global version,
the first two steps are identical,
but then it uses the escaped venue all
way at the very center to say compute
this local average.
So the global version is a special case
of the local version that there is not a
certain waiting governmental if you,
uh,
no, no, no, no, no, uh, um,
that illuminates all support.
This is what you get.
So for each picture location,
you get a scale luminance
between zero and one,
but a global approach and by
the local approach. So here,
it also immediately gives you the
ultimate luminance so that there is no
combination then.
Okay.
The questions?
Yeah.
Okay. Dan, thank you for your attention.
And this concludes this [inaudible]
Aye.